un futur connectés grâce à la fibre
textile
c'est ce que propose l'atelier des
semences à elancourt une innovation avec
des files connectés qui permettent
l'amélioration de ses vêtements en
devenant tactile l'atelier consiste à
coudre du fil conducteur au bout de
doigts de gand qui permet en fait par la
suite utiliser ses gants avec un
téléphone portable donc de l'écran d'un
smartphone ce qui n'est pas possible
normalement quand il sait de la laine
qui est constituée l'extrémité des gants
un mélange entre une pratique ancestrale
et la nouvelle technologie qui
réconcilie les petits comme les grands
avec la couture j'ai un grand plutôt ip
du coup c'est un peu compliqué à coudre
mais après c'est oui c'est vrai c'est
étonnant juste avec un fils de réussir à
bâle taper sur le téléphone et que ça
marche
c'est une étape une étape qui va venir
dans quelques années que nous paraîtra
incontournable un peu comme les
téléphones portables mais à voir son sur
son vêtement une lumière qui annonce par
exemple je sais pas moi un problème
sanguin problèmes de coeur ou un truc
comme ça ou sur même plus une montre on
aura quand même plus besoin d'une montre
on regardera sont plus douces à son
pantalon en or à l'heure voilà et puis
c'est bon quoi avec ces avancées du
futur la meute se retrouvent
révolutionner nouveaux textiles
nouvelles créations mais aussi nouvelles
formes les vêtements se moderniser
change d'aspect le textile électronique
prend une grande place
il ya des recherches qui sont effectués
à la fois par les entreprises par les
fab lab par les centres de recherche
mais aussi par les créateurs des
créations facile à faire et des
nouveautés à retrouver le samedi 4
février à 14h 30 à l'atelier des
sciences à elancourt